[موسيقى]
هذا هو المكان الذي نصور فيه
الآن وهذه يجب أن تكون شقتي
ويجب أن تكون شقة قديمة جدًا
الممثلة الأسطورية يسرا هي
سيدة مصر الرائدة
تمتد مسيرتها المهنية لما يقرب من 50 عامًا ولا
تظهر أي علامات على التباطؤ في أي وقت
قريبًا.  مجموعة من أحدث مسلسلاتها التليفزيونية
تسمى أحلام سعيدة
هي هذه التحف الحقيقية بالطبع
[موسيقى]
بدأت التمثيل في ذروة السينما المصرية
في السبعينيات ،
وازدادت شهرة مسيرتها الفنية في
أواخر الثمانينيات وأوائل التسعينيات
بعد أن ظهرت في أكثر من 80 فيلمًا
وعشرات.  من البرامج التليفزيونية ، لا تزال
مفضلة للأسرة ،
لكن المكان مظلم قليلاً ،
لا بأس ، لكن في بداية حياتها المهنية
، لم يوافق البعض على فكرة عمل النساء في الأفلام
من قبل البعض ،
كنت في التاسعة عشرة من
عمري وكنت صغيرًا جدًا وأتذكر ذلك
في الوقت الذي كنت أعيش فيه مع والدي ،
لذلك عندما قلت
حسنًا أريد أن أتصرف ، قال
ما سأقتلك ، قلت
لماذا أريد أن أتصرف هذه
الوظيفة ، تعود وصمة العار إلى عشرينيات القرن الماضي عندما
كانت الصناعة جديدة
على الرغم من المجتمع.  بدأت النساء
بالتعبير عن أنفسهن من خلال الفيلم ،
لقد كن شجاعات للغاية لأنه في ذلك
الوقت كان من العار العمل في السينما
في العشرينات ،
ولكن
بعد فترة في الثلاثينيات في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
بدأت في
أن تغمرها السينما التي
أصبحت الآن أسطورة هي نفسها.  في مهمة
لدفعها للأمام
بقدر ما ساعدتني الأساطير والنجوم القدامى
في حياتي ، فأنا مدين للأجيال الجديدة
بنسبة ثمانين بالمائة من الجيل الجديد
الذي عملوا معه ، لقد
لعبت دورًا صغيرًا في حياتهم
وهو أمر مهم
[موسيقى]
أنت